الكنيست الاسرائيلي بكامل هيئاته بدا صباح
اليوم مراسم تنصيب حكومه نتنياهو الجديده
وادت الحكومه السابعه والثلاثون اليمين
القانونيه وبذلك تبدا الحكومه الجديده
الاكثر جدليه في تاريخ اسرائيل ولايتها
بشكل رسمي
الذي يهدد اسرائيل والعالم باجمعه
خبرات ميسي
القاء خطابه بسبب المقاطعه من قبل اعضاء
المعارضه الجديده بقياده رئيس الوزراء
السابق يا ارنافيد محاولا عرقله مراسم
تنصيب حكومه نتنياهو
دوله اسرائيل
بتهدئه الاوضاع اصبحت الحكومه الجديده
المعالم ترتكز على احزاب اقصى اليمين
وابقى نتنياهو في قبضه لكود وزاره الدفاع
والخارجيه ووزاره التربيه والتعليم اما
المعارضه الاسرائيليه الجديده فهي قلقه من
ان تاخذ هذه الحكومه اليمنيه دوله اسرائيل
الى مسار ينحرف عن الديمقراطيه مئات
الاسرائيليين تظاهر امام الكنيسه في ظل
اجراءات امنيه مشدده احتجاجا على هذه
الحكومه الجديده التي يصفونها
بالديكتاتوريه ومطالبين باسقاتها لان كل
غاصي من القدس العربيه